okay i wanna hear your vow all right
okay hit me with your best baby yes
baby yeah what would you do if i
got down on my knees nick jonas just
totally trolled shawn mendes i know i
know it feels good
it all started last week when sean
posted this clip to tick-tock
joking quote i've been trying to make a
tick tock for two hours
okay i wanna hear your ba all right okay
hit me with your best baby yes
what would you do if i got down on my
knees
what if i flipped out
okay so it's not great but listen tick
tock is freaking
hard i have the same feeling well on
wednesday
nick took a friendly dig at the senorita
singer posting a side-by-side clip on
instagram taking on sean's tic-tac
challenge
okay i want to hear your bow all right
okay hit me with your best baby yes
baby yeah what would you do if i got
down on my knees
what if i flipped out
wait but this is my favorite part
the 28 year old former disney star
captioned the clip quote
how'd i do shawn mendes it's it's wild
and while shawn has yet to chime in with
his two cents
nick's brother joe jonas was here for it
sliding into the comments with a single
fire emoji
it's amazing and neil patrick harris
he loved it too writing quote hi
hilarious yeah that's what i'd say i
agree nph
hi hilarious it's fun it's good to see
nick
in good spirits and on the mend
following an accident
back in may that left him hospitalized
with a fractured rib
little little injury but i'm i'm gonna
be fine
yeah a little spill um fractured rib and
some other bumps and bruises but
i am feeling really lucky probably could
have been a little worse
and now we finally know what happened
because the accident played out on
wednesday night's pre-taped nbc special
olympic dreams featuring the jonas
brothers they showed the moment nick hit
a curve on a bmx bike
and went down hard causing both of his
brothers
joe and kevin to collide with him and
fall as well
what happened you were riding a bike
what was going what happened
yeah riding a bike uh part you know part
of this
show that we're doing olympic dreams and
and um you know something just
got caught and dirt on the bike and and
just tumbled but uh again i'm i feel i
feel good surprisingly all things
considered and
um you know i was back in my voice chair
right away
kind of said listen i'm not gonna let
this slow me down at all and just
pushing through it but uh
i've got a lot of support around me and
i appreciate everyone's well wishes
means a lot
by the way blake uh said that you were
trying to get the sympathy vote was that
what's going on
yeah i mean this would this would have
been the most elaborate
uh sympathy vote uh of all time um
so i i i think that he's he's as always
being a liar nick may not be a liar but
he knows how to make us laugh baby
yeah what would you do if i got down on
my knees
what if i flipped out